men reach their sexual Market peak in
their late 30s and the thing that women
don't like is they peak in their early
20s and it's always been that way men
have always been success objects to
women and women have always been Beauty
objects to men so men tend to date
younger women men are valued based on on
their competency skills what they can do
um you know that like that little Dent
that they can put in the universe sort
of thing whereas men don't usually care
about women's degrees there's no guy
that ever said oh yeah look at the
degree on her they're visual in a sense
that they see women as Beauty objects
and they've always been treated as
Beauty objects even though Society tries
to change that today so Peak then for
women's appearance is earlier value
actually
um women have valued men based on what
they can bring to the table right like
what resources they have available to
them to provide and preside over the
family and the children and protect and
all that sort of stuff uh women's value
has historically always been around
their beauty and their fertility